[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
la fin du ramadan pour les musulmans de
france alors que le gouvernement a
autorisé hier la reprise des cérémonies
religieuses
les représentants des cultes appelle les
fidèles à la prudence et à ne pas se
rendre dans les mosquées
sur le plan économique la dette
française va sans doute dépassé les 115%
du pib à la fin de l'année déclaration
du ministre des comptes publics gérald
darmanin qui cumule depuis hier sa
fonction avec celle de maire de
tourcoing
[Musique]
le procès pour corruption de benyamin
nétanyahou ajournée au bout d'une heure
d'audience les manifestations de soutien
et des manifestations de protestation
devant le tribunal du district de
jérusalem pour ce premier procès de
l'histoire d'israël visant un chef de
gouvernement en fonction entouré de ses
partisans le premier ministre israélien
a qualifié ces accusations de ridicules
[Musique]
un nouveau virus politique se propage
aux états unis déclarations du chef de
la diplomatie chinoise
sur fond de crise sanitaire l'escaladé
verbale se poursuit entre pékin et
washington
des 15 s'est déclaré aujourd'hui au bord
d'une nouvelle guerre froide avec
washington donald trump qui a évoqué
récemment la possibilité de demander des
milliards de dollars de dédommagements à
la chine qu'il tient pour responsable de
la propagation du virus
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche fin du
ramadan pour les musulmans de france et
reprise des messes pour les chrétiens en
ce premier dimanche après l'ascension
les cérémonies religieuses ont repris
depuis hier dans les églises
pendant deux mois les messes ont été
célébrées cents fidèles et sur internet
l'autorisation de revenir dans les lieux
saints étaient très attendus regardez je
l'attendais le fait de se retrouver de
voir en fait déjà de revoir l'église de
voir les gens de prier ensemble en fait
parce que le problème c'est pas de
briller tout seul à la maison mais
d'être vraiment dans la maison de dieu
et tous on est venu avec nos intentions
nos douleurs et tous de le faire
ensemble
on est venu bien en avance pour être sûr
d'avoir d'avoir une place et voilà
retrouver toute la communauté tous les
visages qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis deux
mois c'était c'était super de vivre ça
tous ensemble on a trouvé ça très bien
fait voilà tout était très bien préparé
deux place rouge où fallait pas
s'asseoir une place verte réservé pour
chaque personne m'ont même en famille on
a respecté sa bien qu'on vive ensemble
tout le temps finalement on a bien
respecté ces voix là on a trouvé que
toutes les consignes étaient très bien
respectée ça s'est très bien passé et ça
me manquait beaucoup parce que je
suivais les mains sur kto et là est
présente à la messe dans une église
c'est plus humain on voit le prête moi
je préfère ça que est devant une
tablette ou son écran de télévision
les conséquences de la crise sur le plan
économique en france la dette française
estimée à plus de 115 % du pib à la fin
de l'année déclaration de gérald
darmanin aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics annonce
également une exonération des charges
sociales à hauteur de 3 milliards
d'euros pour les entreprises les plus
impactés par le confinement
gérald darmanin qui a repris hier ses
fonctions de maire de tourcoing tout en
gardant son poste de ministre
avant la crise l'exécutif avait pourtant
averti pas de cumul il faudra choisir
regardez et comme c'est une entreprise
pme françaises d'une pme européennes qui
veulent en angleterre et près de fait
ces déclarations ne pas payer ses droits
restent sur le territoire
à lorient il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du bon usage de la force policière c'est
la tribune publiée aujourd'hui dans le
jdd parrain l'ancien dirigeant de la
fédération autonome des syndicats de
police il dit craindre des agressions
contre les forces de l'ordre avec un
retour en force des manifestations
sociales et ils appellent en conséquence
le gouvernement à interdire une fois
n'est pas coutume lusage des fameux lbd
les lanceurs de balles de défense il
appelle aussi à renforcer les effectifs
regardez outre la tragédie humaine la
crise sanitaire du coc vide 19 va
provoquer une crise sociale de grande
ampleur les forces publiques de sécurité
seront essentiellement utilisés pour des
missions de maintien de l'ordre
or nous avons déjà vécu plus de 15 mois
de conflits sociaux
lors de ces manifestations les forces de
police ont été victimes de violences
parfois graves
les pouvoirs publics doivent interdire
l'usagé des ailes bd comme demandé par
le défenseur des droits
jacques toubon et ils doivent augmenter
les salaires des gardiens de la paix
augmenter leurs effectifs développer
leur formation et leur enseignement et
on écoute justement jean louis à raja
l'auteur de cette tribune
on s'est rendu compte avec la crypte du
cosy 19 combien la crise était
importante au niveau du personnel
hospitalier et bien je crains que demain
parce que la police ne peut pas tout
faire la police ne peut pas régler tous
les problèmes de notre société
eh bien je crains que demain on puisse à
nouveau percevoir cette fois la crise du
service public de sécurité
ses collègues croyez moi ils sont
excédés une un peu plus un balèze dont
on parle moins aujourd'hui
mais qui est vraiment profond au sein de
la police nationale et et je crains je
crains vraiment que à nouveau il y ait
de très gros incident quoi elle nous a
bassinés pendant des années avec les
restrictions budgétaires on a fait ce
qu'on appelait à la police les
suppressions de postes une nouvelle
répartition des compétences entre police
et gendarmerie
on a engagé il ya encore 2 3 a prétexté
d'ailleurs la police de sécurité au
quotidien ce qu'on a appelé
mutualisation en fait on fermer
certaines bases territoriales pour
renforcer notre base territoriale
ce qui fait que et vit là bas les bases
sur lesquelles il est plus d'effectifs
étaient complètement délaissé la seule
chose qu on demande à nos collègues
c'est de faire plus toujours plus avec
de moins en moins de moyens
on leur demande de surtout d'être
rentable il ya la notion de rentabilité
aujourd'hui qui est rentré au niveau de
la police nationale ce qui est une
aberration totale
la reprise du tourisme en europe en
ordre dispersé les touristes sont
autorisés à revenir en espagne début
juillet il donne pour l'italie et alors
que la france et le royaume uni s impose
des mises en quarantaine réciproque
la france qui prône toujours des
vacances tricolore pour essayer de
sauver une filière en danger
économiquement
la commission européenne doit d'ailleurs
présenter son plan de relance économique
mercredi
mathilde romagnan des plages qui
accueille de nouveau les vacanciers
avant l'ouverture des frontières ces
images donnent de l'espoir aux
professionnels du tourisme mais aussi
aux visiteurs enfin libre après des
semaines de confinement mais dans la
tente d'une très probable venue des
touristes tous les pays
n'agissent pas de la même façon la
commission européenne a pourtant émis
des recommandations sanitaires mais sans
la moindre garantie qu'elles soient
respectées
la chancelière allemande a donc appelé à
l'unité de la société heine zeit
southern china europa c'est pourquoi le
moment est venu d'être unie en europe
est de montrer que nous voulons rester
forts ensemble le gouvernement fédéral
s'y est engagé danse en ce qui concerne
les programmes d'être européen que sur
l'organisation de notre présidence au
cours des six prochains mois à partir du
1er juillet rien nous veillerons à ce
que l'europe sorte de cette crise en
continuant à se battre ensemble pour la
paix et la prospérité schifrin
au final chaque état membre fait un peu
comme bon lui semble au nom de la santé
publique les pays de l'espace schengen
pouvait espérer se coordonner sur ce
point mais déjà en mars lors du
confinement et de la fermeture des
frontières aucun d'entre eux n'avait
demandé l'avis de son voisin est l'enjeu
et pas que sanitaire à lui seul le
secteur touristique pèse 11 % du pib
européen la france et l'espagne attire
par exemple 90 et 80 millions de
touristes chaque année moins visité le
royaume uni tout juste sortis de lui
montre son opposition à bruxelles
face au nombre de morts dus qu'aux vite
19 le pays envisage la mise en place
d'une 14ème à l'arrivée sur son sol nous
effectuerons des vérifications
ponctuelles d'ici la mi juin pour nous
assurer que les personnes s'isole et les
étrangers qui refusent de se conformer
aux règles pourraient se voir refuser
l'entrée dans le pays
toute personne ne respectant pas la
14ème pourrait encourir une pénalité de
1000 livres
cela sera un avis de pénalité
financement et éventuellement cela
pourrait également entraîner des
poursuites potentielles et une amende
illimité pour non respect de ces
sanctions
réponse cinglante de paris il en sera de
même pour le ressortissant britannique
avant une possible entente entre les
vingt-sept d'ici à l'été
les européens se préparent à passer
leurs vacances dans leur propre pays
aux antipodes de l'idéal communautaire
et puis sachez qu'en italie quelques 400
migrants ont été débarqués illégalement
ce dimanche sur une plage de sicile dans
le sud du pays il aurait était à l'essai
par un bateau à quelques mètres du
rivage d'une plage dans la région
d'aghribs nt à leurs embarcations non
identifié ensuite repris le large des
recherches de police par hélicoptère ont
été ordonnées dans cette zone
en israël le procès pour corruption de
benyamin nétanyahou a été ajournée au
bout d'une heure seulement d'audience
des manifestations de soutien et des
manifestations de protestation loyer
devant le tribunal du district de
jérusalem
pour ce premier procès de l'histoire
décret il enfin un chef de gouvernement
aux fonctions entouré de ses partisans
le premier ministre israélien a qualifié
ces accusations de ridicules écouter le
norisring machault médaillon de muespach
citoyens d'israël ce qui est jugé
aujourd'hui c'est le désir d'éliminer la
volonté du peuple
la tentative de me renverser le camp de
la droite plus d'une décennie là
il n'y est pas parvenu dans les sondages
alors ces dernières années elle a
proposé un nouveau schéma des sources de
la police et du bureau du procureur
jointe aux journaux de gauche
je les appelle le groupe i just not be
be mais quand même bravo rate raclot bus
afin de personnaliser les cas sans
fondement et l'imaginaire l'objectif est
de destituer un premier ministre de
droite fort c'est-à-dire d'écarter le
camp nationaliste de la direction de
l'état pendant de nombreuses années
qu'est ce que ça peut leur faire si un
caniche obéissant de la droite arrive il
y en a toujours mais je ne suis pas un
caniche avait même eu un énorme pot 2 et
voyez à présent l'analyse de jacques
benillouche spécialiste en politique
israélienne tanya voit toujours c'est un
petit peu dans la dramaturgie et quand
ce n'est pas dans le spectacle c'est une
bête politique mais surtout un grand un
grand acteur et on a vu tout à l'heure
une image qui est un petit peu une mise
en scène d'un parent entouré de ses
principaux ministres du likoud tous
masqués contre le corps d'un virus
évidemment et qui ont fait une entrée
spectaculaire dans vos tribunal ça
rappelle des films qu'on a vu au cinéma
d'un parent qui circulent avec toutes
ses troupes et là à d'ailleurs refusé
parce que son image cette image là d'un
de 2,2 suspect vis-à-vis d'un tribunal
il a d'ailleurs refusé de s'asseoir tant
que sur le banc des accusés et les bons
d'état famille comme il a dit jusqu'à ce
que les caméras quitte la salle
d'audience
dernier week end ramadan pour les
musulmans du monde entier est une fête
perturber cette année par la crise
sanitaire avec des festivités est
réduite au minimum
voyez ce reportage en tunisie de nos
reporters bassam chebbi et sert nasri
journée assez exceptionnel en tunisie
dans l'ensemble du monde musulman
aujourd'hui les musulmans de la planète
entière célèbrent l'aïd el fitr qui
clôture un mois de ramadhan un ramadan
qui a été vécue de manière
exceptionnelle à cause du coronavirus un
confinement respectés et appliqués dans
l'ensemble des pays et musulmans des
mosquées est fermé des prières qui ont
dû avoir lieu à la maison pour l'aïd el
fitr cette année même règle la
célébration de la fête n'a été fait
à domicile les mosquées sont restés
fermés une grande première comme vous
pouvez voir juste derrière moi nous
sommes sur le parvis de la mosquée
zitouna la grande mosquée du tennis qui
est resté fermé une grande première dans
son histoire je vous propose d'écouter
l'intendant de la grande mosquée tunis
de la médina de tunis c'est bien triste
aujourd'hui c'est différent des autres
années
des gens avaient l'habitude de se rendre
visite et de célébrer cette fête
ensemble dans les cafés qui sont
d'habitude bondés on vivait avant cette
crise une ambiance assez festive durant
le ramadan et pendant la fête de l'aïd
et à la grande mosquée en temps normal
dès 7 heures du matin il était quasiment
impossible de trouver une place
tellement les fidèles arrivaient en
masse pour la prière de l'aïd et après
la fin de la prière tout le monde
s'embrasse et se souhaiter bonne fête
tout le monde était heureux
c'était vraiment la fête pour retrouver
nos familles nos amis
c'est comme ça que ça devrait se passer
en tunisie
comme vous pouvez le constater derrière
moi les ruelles de la médina sont
anormalement vide en temps normal après
la célébration à la mosquée les
tunisiens ont l'habitude de se pavaner
dans ses ruelles profiter des cafés et
des restaurants mais cette année
exceptionnellement le gouvernement a
décidé d'instaurer un couvre-feu un
compliment obligatoire pour cette
journée pour éviter tout contact et
respecté des gestes-barrières objectif
éviter une deuxième vague de kobe 19
en tunisie le gouvernement espère que
tunisien respecteront cette règle en
attendant ad confinement total prévu
pour le 14 juin prochain et je vous
propose à présent un tour du monde en
images de cette fin de ramadan regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
pour
non
[Musique]
bon
ans
[Musique]
où
le ton
[Musique]
pour
et à l'occasion de la fin de ce ramadan
cessez le feu a été décrété en
afghanistan une trêve de trois jours
conclue entre les talibans et le pouvoir
en place c'est une première depuis 2001
le président afghan a annoncé la
libération d'environ 2000 prisonniers
insurgés c'est une avancée dans un
processus de paix entre ces deux camps
après des mois de violences écoute et
justement ashraf ghani le président
afghan
je me félicite une fois de plus de
l'annnonce du cessez le feu par les
talibans a obéi koch pas mais pour
l'amener à ti hier soir j'ai donné
l'ordre à toutes les forces de sécurité
de défense de respecter ce cessez le feu
est de rester sur la défensive
quand la rolex à 6-6 par conséquent la
seule solution est d'entamer les
pourparlers de paix hayate aux crs et la
délégation de négociation afghane
iam est prête à entamer immédiatement
les pourparlers de paix avec les
talibans dit kai and ancient de la
barouette à ce mail la table la personne
stone nomades l iphone
un nouveau virus politique se propage
aux états unis la déclaration est signée
du chef de la diplomatie chinoise sur
fond de crise sanitaire l'escaladé
verbale se poursuit donc entre pékin et
washington et pékin qui s'est déclaré
aujourd'hui je cite au bord d'une
nouvelle guerre froide avec washington
donald trump a évoqué récemment la
possibilité de demander des milliards de
dollars de dédommagements à la chine
qu'il tient pour responsable de la
propagation du virus
voyez la réaction de pékin la chine
qu'aux aspects liés à notre grand regret
outre la dévastation causée par le
nouveau coronavirus pour un virus
politique se propage aux états unis ce
virus politique saisir toutes les
occasions pour attaquer diffamé la chine
comme timorés certains politiciens
américains indépendamment des faits dont
on fabrique trop de mensonges et
fomenter trop de complot maintenant nous
devons être vigilants contre certaines
forces politiques américaines qui
prennent en otage les relations entre la
chine et les états unis et pousse nos
deux pays au bord d'une nouvelle guerre
froide
la chine qui a averti que la loi sur la
sécurité nationale visant ton qu'on
devra s'appliquer sans délai annonce
faite ce matin alors que des
manifestants vous le voyez
antigouvernementaux se sont confrontés
aux forces de l'ordre
la contestation sociale qui a donc
repris sur ce territoire
ils sont des milliers à être descendus
dans les rues pour dénoncer ce texte
déposé vendredi au parlement de pékin et
qui doit être votée très prochainement
hong kong qui a déjà connu plusieurs
mois de protestations l'an passé voyez
le récapitulatif des dates clés de ce
mécontentement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
on
[Musique]
en
on nous
[Musique]
pas
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nouvel épicentre de cette pandémie après
les états unis elle touche à présent
l'amérique latine et les caraïbes avec
de sérieuses conséquences notamment dans
les prisons des centres de détention
souvent surpeuplées et insalubres ou les
mesures sanitaires ne peuvent être
appliquées en argentine certains détenus
demandent maintenant à être assigné à
résidence
rania berrada et ricardo romero nous
sommes à la prison de devo tôt à buenos
aires
ces images ont été tournées par un
détenu on y voit un bâtiment insalubre
délit à 40 cm de distance l'un de
l'autre et des salles communes surpeuplé
dans un entretien avec art et alejandro
guevara à l'origine de cette vidéo
alerte sur les risques sanitaires qu'ils
encourent en pleine pandémie
je souffre d'asthme et d'une maladie
pulmonaire obstructive chronique parce
que je fume contaminée par le
coronavirus je serais mort en moins de
24 heures
alejandro qui purge des derniers mois
d'une peine de 24 ans a demandé une
assignation à résidence qui a été
rejetée
depuis le début de la propagation du
virus plusieurs instances judiciaires
ont recommandé de remplacer les peines
de prison par des mesures alternatives
en vain les conséquences de cette sourde
oreille pourraient être dramatiques
selon certains experts
si le problème de la surpopulation
carcérale demeure il entraînera des
problèmes sanitaires
nous constatons une situation déjà
problématique au pérou en colombie et
dans certaines prisons américaines dont
les trois quarts des détenus sont
malades
si le virus se propage parmi les
prisonniers ici également
cela entraînera une crise dans les
hôpitaux la population générale doit
être soigné selon le ministère de la
santé argentin seuls 2% de l'ensemble
des détenus des prisons fédérales ont
été placés en résidence surveillée en
raison des risques sanitaires
bien que faible ce pourcentage est jugée
inacceptable par les défenseurs des
droits des victimes et sa levée totale
mine king route et saluons cape town qui
n'est moins mal c'est complètement 1
c'est une décision très difficile à
vivre je pense que les autorités devrait
abroger ces mesures et rendre un peu
plus justice aux victimes qui ont vécu
toutes ces horreurs ce sera à nous de
veiller dans les années à venir à ce que
les criminels qui tuent violent enlève
nos enfants purgé leur peine comme il se
doit ces dernières semaines plusieurs
organisations internationales ont
qualifiée d'alarmante la situation
carcérale en amérique latine notamment
au brésil en colombie et au pérou
en réponse à ces inquiétudes les
autorités argentines ont promis de créer
des places supplémentaires dans les
prisons et des centres de détention
provisoire pays le plus touché du
continent le brésil avec un millier de
décès en moyenne par jour et parmi les
personnes les plus vulnérables il ya
bien sûr les personnes âgées mais aussi
celles qui sont atteints d'un handicap
voyez le témoignage de ce médecin
brésilien il est lui-même paraplégique
et il travaille dans un hôpital du
nord-est du brésil
lorsque le patient arrive à l'hôpital
s'ils présentent des symptômes suspects
de coliques 19 nous la menons dans une
zone d'isolement où je change de
fauteuils roulants
quand je rentre chez moi j'ai un autre
fauteuil dans le garage car le mien est
théoriquement infectés en raison de
l'afflux de personnes à l'hôpital et je
dois faire attention pour ne pas
infecter ma maison les accessoires comme
les fauteuils roulants sont plus faciles
à contaminer comme les roues et des
autres parties de la chaise mais
j'essaie d'être prudent dans la
désinfection enfin de ne pas être
infecté
je fais mon travail le mieux que je peux
rester avec nous à suivre notre magazine
d'actualité on se retrouve quant à nous
dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous
[Musique]
oh